la recette que je vous propose pour les
fêtes de fin d'année est prévu un filet
de marc fin à la sauce grand veneur vous
prenez après beau fils et vous le faites
mariner deux jours avec du sel du poivre
de l'oignon de l'ail du thym du laurier
des grains de genièvre et après au bout
de deux jours vous retirer votre fils et
de ma carrière vous l'épongé bien vous
prenez
dans une casserole du beurre un peu
d'huile et vous faites sauter des
carottes des douanes font du thym du
laurier et vous paraît avec les parures
du filet que vous mettez dans la
casserole vous mouillez avec un
décilitre de bouillon la marinade un
verre de vinaigre de xérès et vous
laissez cuire une heure quand le tout
est bien cuit vous tamiser la sauce vous
la remettez dans une autre dans une
autre casserole vous la laissez épaissir
quand elle est bien homogène
vous mettez votre fils est dans un plat
vous mettez du sel du poivre un peu des
rues de pau vente du beurre un peu
d'huile
vous le passez au four pendant 25
minutes
mon plat et nappez j'ai mis une cuillère
de purée de marrons un peu de crème
fraîche un peu de groseilles et mon plat
est terminée on peut se permettre de
manger ce plat pour le noël et jour de
l'an c'est un prix assez raisonnable
tout le monde peut acquérir un bon plat
comme ça pour passer de très bonnes
fêtes